la la vraie question que nous on se pose
est-ce que c'est vraiment Harry dans le
fond qui est vénère envers son père ou
est-ce qu'il est entièrement sous la
est-ce qu'il aurait dit à son père
certaines actrices de fin duchesse
[Rires]
apparemment Harry qu'est-ce qu'il a
Harry et Megane ils veulent faire quoi
absolument jeudi à 21h heure française
précise en même temps que votre creuse
rigolade exactement il fait partie de la
grosse rigolade il sera ah oui
et donc ce sera diffusé les trois
premiers documents à faire les trois
premières les trois premières parties
les trois premiers épisodes merci de
cette fameuse série qui est en
préparation depuis 2020 qui s'appelle
Houari et Mégane et dans lequel ils vont
révéler nous distillent toute la vérité
ou du moins toute leur vérité à eux
concernant ce qu'ils ont vécu au sein de
cette institution vous savez qu'ils ont
déjà taxé de racistes chez Oprah Winfrey
et alors on part donc
avec bah bon nombre de personnes au sein
de cette famille royale avec qui ils
auraient les tensions alors la
bande-annonce qui dure une minute trente
a été diffusée la semaine dernière
évidemment elle a été diffusée le jour
où William et Ken arrivé à Boston alors
que c'était leur premier déplacement
officiel en tant que Prince et princesse
de Galles donc on voit déjà qu'il y a à
côté tension et
cette annonce qui dure une minute trente
merci de me laisser parler
elle nous montre déjà en angle très
américain juste essentiellement le
marché américain et un angle de
vengeance puisque je reprends une seule
fois
ah ça va toi
tu te calmes tu
[Applaudissements]
tu es nul alors qu'est-ce que c'est quoi
là
ne connais toute l'histoire nous nous
connaissons toute l'histoire
du salon vous la raconter et à ce
moment-là qu'est-ce que l'on voit une
photo de William et de Kate qui apparaît
à l'arrière-plan qui tire un peu la tête
et Mégane qui arrive et qui se cache les
yeux parce que parfois elle se serait en
train de pleurer elle était un chat
total
qui est Mégane pour le coup elle était
une chaîne à Total et ce que l'on
redoute
à nouveau les détention vont être à
nouveau activer
absolument mais on en est à un point
Cyril deux petites secondes simplement
pour vous dire que le Daily Mail de ce
matin titre c'est la guerre civile le
dénime titre guerre civile qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire guerre civile ça veut dire
que c'est des taxes en Angleterre qui
sont le premier pouvoir il faut quand
même savoir que l'étable lui sont le
premier pouvoir en Angleterre liste
désormais vous choisissez ou vous êtes
du côté Windsor vous êtes du côté palais
du du devoir de l'obligation du service
ou vous êtes du côté américain du côté
Harry du côté Mégane du côté Kardashian
[Rires]
tout ce que tu veux
aussi un énorme contact avec Netflix on
parle de 100 millions de dollars il
paraît 99 qui galèrent à l'honorer il
devait faire ça et de faire des dessins
animés ils arrivent pas à les faire ma
question c'est est-ce qu'ils en font pas
des caisses pour dire à Netflix voilà
vous en avez pour votre argent est-ce
qu'il y a pas une question financière
est-ce qu'il balance
99 millions pour un documentaire qui a
été dit en trois fois pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils se sont précipités de le sortir
parce que le dernier paiement les 33
derniers million il est touche
maintenant il est touché à la diffusion
en effet pour 99 millions il devait pas
se contenter de dire écoutez tout va
bien merveilleuse et la reine Élisabeth
il était très sympathique donc on
s'attend vraiment à ce qu'il y ait des
choses c'est même pas croustillant c'est
indécent c'est vraiment indécent
et alors pourquoi ont-ils choisi le
casque c'est une date qui tient très
fort à cœur Delton parce que c'est ce
soir-là qu'elle va réunir vraiment la
crème de la crème en Angleterre pour un
grand concert caritatif
donc tout cela pour vous dire que à
nouveau même dans les dates qui ont été
choisies pour la diffusion de ce
documentaire là on est dans un hôtel
dans un côté
il y a en plus la deuxième couche c'est
qu'il sorte un livre aussi à Harry sors
un livre chez Fayard en France qui va
aussi être une bombe et absolument le
documentaire est la première partie
d'une bombe dont la deuxième le en effet
le deuxième volet c'est le 10 janvier
super en effet le suppléant qui paraîtra
aux éditions pinguin en Angleterre
traduit chez fayards et là il dit en
quatrième de couverture qu'il revient
sur les son enfance donc à nouveau moi
ce qui m'énerve un peu si je peux deux
secondes c'est que en permanence il surf
sur cette vague de racisme de voilà il
manque que ça voilà et ce que je veux
dire existe à travers le la salissure de
leur famille à lui je ne dis pas qu'ils
n'ont pas souffert à un moment donné il
utilise un terme très particulier il dit
j'ai voulu dans une famille
ingérarchisée il a entièrement raison
seul contre le chef d'État à savoir que
c'était Elisabeth de maintenant c'est
Charles III et puis les descendants
directs il a raison mais ça il le savait
en quelque sorte est-ce que je veux dire
c'est que si il n'avait pas tous ces
éléments tous ces arguments contre la
famille royale
19 millions d'euros et et jamais il ne
il ne parviendrait à rassembler autant
de monde on rappelle quand même aussi
que Netflix en Angleterre a augmenté le
prix de son abonnement tellement ils
sont persuadés on annonce jeudi qu'il y
aura personne dans les rues en
Angleterre il y aura personne en France
on peut regarder que ça la grosse
rigolade mais en Angleterre ils sont
tous devant
[Applaudissements]
aux côtés du roi Charles III et de la
famille royale mais c'est pour vous dire
une tension incroyable qui s'est formée
et que pour moi les deux clans sont
désormais irréconciliables j'ai presque
fini
en plus
ça veut dire comme tu es beau comme tu
oui en plus les accusations de racisme
il y a la marraine de William qui est
dans un tourmente parce que elle arrête
de faire une dame et donc ça vient
ajouter de l'eau au moulin de de Harry
et il y a ce soir le fait on est le 6
décembre qu'ils sont actuellement à
l'hôtel Hilton de Londres il reçoit
avoir pris contre le racisme un prix qui
est remis par la Fondation Robert
Fitzgerald Kennedy donc et en effet
alors il y a eu la dame d'honneur
l'ancienne très très ami très proche
d'Elizabeth de Lady Suzanne
83 ans qui alors en effet aurait formulé
des paroles un peu raciste si vraiment
on décryp la chose elle a fait répéter
trois fois exactement le le nom et le et
la provenance exacte du village d'une
jeune dame qui en effet été marre de pas
il faut quand même savoir que la 83 ans
et en plus c'est vrai c'est la fresque
elle a des petits problèmes de oui elle
l'a fait répéter trois fois alors je dis
pas du tout que mais en tout cas j'en
peux plus moi j'ai la fenêtre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]